Evaluate 1x when x is equal to
negative 1, x is equal to 0,
and x is equal to 1.
So let's do the scenario
x is equal to negative 1.
Then 1x becomes 1 times x,
which is now negative 1.
So it's 1 times negative 1.
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
1 times anything is going
to be that anything.
So 1 times negative 1 is going
to be equal to negative 1.
Another way you could
have thought about it
is you could've just looked
at the absolute value
of both numbers.
You'd say 1 times 1 is 1.
They have different signs.
So it's going to be negative.
It would have gotten you
the same answer either way.
Now we have the scenario
where x is equal to 0.
So 1 times x is going to be
the same thing as 1 times 0.
We've substituted a 0 for x.
Once again, 1 times anything is
going to become that anything.
So this is going to become 0.
Another way to think about
it is 0 times anything
is going to become 0.
So either one of those
ways of thinking about it
would have gotten
you this answer.
1 times-- actually,
we could even
write 1 times x is equal to x.
So really, when you
evaluate any of these
at x is equal to negative 1, or
x is equal to 0, or x equals 1,
it's really just going
to equal that number
because 1 times anything
is equal to that anything
right over there.
Just to make it clear, 0
times anything is equal to--
and this x here is a variable
not a multiplication sign-- 0
times anything is equal to 0.
Just for good measure--
we kind of already
went over the answer-- but
let's try x is equal to 1.
So this will give us 1 times
1, which you've probably
learned a while ago.
But 1 times anything is
equal to that number.
So it's equal to 1.